I need to talk about something for a
second it's been like two or three weeks
since I lost tried to do some Spanish
architecture and rot like Oh second
three after which I was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I gave up on the Nights play park
I've done loads of stuff in their manes
in their main time by the way yeah I
kind of need to apologize for that as
well I'm kind of busy with stuff at the
moment like there's some real life stuff
going on and there's also some one
showdown on the Chagos world last month
that was the creators lounge contest
which I post which I put most of my
effort into and some random other Oct 3
projects so I don't really have too much
time to work on this let's play at the
moment but I actually got quite inspired
and I really wanted to do this and that
was what brings me to as to why and what
I'm actually doing right here because
basically I figured the Spanish thing
was just not working out I really kind
of sucked at that which was well mostly
due to the fact that usually what I said
I was going to do and what I have done
for most of the things that I've built
lately is go to Google Images go
anywhere just ask for as much of help as
I can get on a certain theme and get
just enough inspiration and ideas and
also knowledge about that before I jump
into it whereas for the Spanish theme it
was just going with whatever I felt was
Spanish and it really didn't work out it
was also a bit of a farmer area house
that I turned it into which is really
probably not the best idea
so then blackouts in one of the streams
where I once again complained about the
fact that I can't do [ __ ] in here
blackout actually said yo you need to
look at like Madrid and big cities in
Spain and do something like that so I
did that I actually looked up some of
that stuff and it checked out was like
typically Spanish and things and instead
of what I had so far in the let's play
park I'm gonna have to go for a much
more City big city ish
way of doing the theme in that area so
it is not going to be like with the
little houses and the fun little bars
and things but rather big classical
buildings with arches and pillars and
all that amazing stuff
now that might actually be a good thing
because I was kind of missing that from
Verona Valley like
the reasons why one likes working on
Verona Valley but also also why it was
so easy to make it look impressive is
the fact that it's in the classical
architecture style which is usually used
to you know impress people to show off
your in your huge wealth and just
basically decorate everything until it's
over decorated and you decorate it and
just don't give a [ __ ] about shapes or
measurements or anything like that so
that's why that's an easy thing to do
and really amazing to just pull off and
make something look really awesome in a
theme park and that was something that I
was not going to have in this park at
first if I would go with that standard
farm type Spanish architecture but now
that I'm going with the the classical
more big-city architecture I might as
well get built France in there you know
it is also of course some Italian
influences in that as long as I or just
as long as I also just spend the
tsipras's that should be completely fine
and yeah that's basically about that so
big classical buildings is what we can
probably expect from this also I was
just messing up when I was trying to
build this building like I don't even
know in hindsight what I was even trying
to do here I really didn't have too much
ideas of what I should do
basically this was me doing that you
know open up a new park file and see
what a theme is all about and just try
messing with pieces and try actually
build something this was actually not
supposed to be a time lapse let me make
that clear but in the end it turned into
a building which I figured I might
actually want to use in the park it was
not something that I planned beforehand
but it kind of turned into that so
that's why I decided might as well share
that's her since I do want to share as
much as I can of the pike so yeah the
first half of this time lapse is just
going to be working on this building
finishing this in a map that is not the
actual let's play Park itself but then
after I have done that export it to that
map put it into the area where I want it
and you know do some type of that and
that is basically how this is going to
work one of the things I think I looked
at like a standard corner building where
you just have one big Tower round ish
thing at the corner and
along both sides you just have those
straight classical facades and that's
basically what this is kind of going for
no idea what exactly it is I'm making
the most stupid hand gestures at the
moment and I need to not make this
commentary even more awkward than it
already is
so yeah best remedy for that is actually
talk about the building thing is this is
classical architecture in a way that
we've seen it before
it's just with more of a Spanish idea
but it's really hard to even define that
since it isn't overall you know
classical thing I'm actually gonna have
to look into how that exactly works you
know probably not in a way that I've
looked at the difference of Chinese
Korean and Japan Japanese architecture
which is actually really a thing and
after I've read that I can't even see
any Asian park in rollerCoaster Tycoon 3
because everybody thinks okay it's Asian
it's alright but it turns out there are
actually more differences in Japanese
Chinese and Korean architecture than I
figured beforehand and I think with
Spanish Italian and French this is
definitely the case and I'm I really
keep any two like the big cities since
obviously the you know the the Spanish
kind of well it's it's very hard to say
the Spanish is this really hot even this
difference alright it's just it's hard
to define it and that is why I need to
research that so glad we got that
cleared up also I wanted to change the
layout of the Train I just figured you
know I might as well let the train not
just right like around the borders of
the park and just get the train actually
in the park itself and maybe do some
cool train stations but that is
something for like a completely
different episode and I'll do that in
the future but yeah that's where the
building is going to be right now all
the light brown stuff is planned
buildings and all the grey ish tiles are
obviously going to be the part and
that's like the basic planning over here
and over here I would figure I figured I
would just get a couple of simple
facades done before I really move on to
anything I don't know if I'm really
explain this too much but yeah this is
going to be the basic planning is that
I'm going to have facades around this
little area
and then the the ground that has kind of
lowered over there it's got to be a
little pond where the log flume
hopefully that is actually going to fit
where the log flume is going to have its
drop and where you can just kind of walk
around that's maybe you have some some
nice little waterside restaurants things
like that maybe you one other attraction
and yeah that'll be about this area so
it's gonna be kind of City but then
again on the side of the log flume I'm
gonna have a pretty large Mountain that
the log flume can use to just kind of
have a cool drop and things like that
though I want to put some buildings on
that too it is all just very vague and
there's not really too much planning on
it the main idea was basically choppers
but with a Spanish theme there I said it
that is basically how it is though I
don't really want to rip off anything
too much like thatis that is something I
almost feel like I've done too much
lately like this Park was almost going
to completely rip off Disneyland which
is why I'm going to completely rip I'm
going to not have any central castle or
anything like that I do want to have a
castle in the Japanese area as well as
probably the Alpine or Romanian area
which is kind of in the middle but
neither of them is going to be a central
a central kind of car so in a way that
Disney has won and I don't even think
I'm going to have anything large at the
end of a the main street I think
somebody said I think King rct3 said
that was called a uini we have like a
really large building at the end of the
Main Street and Disney and you're like
in the beginning of the Main Street and
you're like oh wow that's a huge
building over that looks beautiful we're
gonna walk through woods now or
something in psychology and like I said
I don't know [ __ ] about that but that is
something that I'm going to leave out
sadly since I don't think there's
anything that I can add to the park
without breaking the themes that I
currently have since Disney castles
Castle is alright since you can see the
castle from the entire park but the
entire park is themed after Disney so
even if you're in like the the Pirates
area you still feel like yeah we're in
Disneyland that's how things work over
here but I feel like in this park
it would just be too weird if you were
and say the Japanese parts and you see
this amazing
huge either European Council next to
that or acaso which was another idea I
call so that mixes all of the different
themes in the park but that still
probably wouldn't work since that would
be one way to awkward trying to fit all
those themes into one building and also
just immersion breaking in any kind of
theme that you want to be in so yeah I'm
going to leave that out and the only
type of really that the Main Street is
going to have is that small swing is
chair swing thing at the end of it I
can't even speak at the moment also I
would like to I would like to really
quickly express my my love for pets
efteling set roofs I think those roofs
work better as a Spanish roof then the
Spanish roof tiles set and this is
probably something that I've complained
about earlier but the Spanish style sat
just it is so bright and I know this is
a theme park but it is just weird and
awkwardly bright it's really great for
something for some things I think it's
an amazing texture for modern buildings
but if I want to get some classical
Spanish architecture I think that the
pets efteling set is actually going to
be better than that though I have to be
careful since it's also the set that I
am planning on using for my Dutch roofs
so yeah that that is hopefully still
going to work out but I don't know now
at this point I do feel like by the way
the buildings don't really look too
Spanish ich just generally classical but
they were inspired by many well by a
couple of Spanish buildings that I've
seen so I think it should work alright
in the end anyway that's it for this
episode I'll see you all next episode in
which I'll probably make a couple more
facades so I'll be decision and I'll see
you then